so I want to welcome you to the Yale
broadcast Center my name is Robin Hogan
I'm the deputy director of public
affairs at Yale and this is a first for
us we've never used this wonderful new
facility to tape a program that will be
broadcast on the Discover Magazine
website the John Templeton Foundation is
underwriting this program tonight very
generously and a series of programs like
this all over the country on the theme
of the big questions answering posing
very the big questions they have a
wonderful brochure of essays on this
topic which we'll be distributing at the
reception at the end of our program
now our moderator tonight we're
delighted that Corey Powell after
spending four years in that dreadful
town up on the Cambridge Harvard
University has decided to pass like a
dream to see the light and to to come to
New Haven tonight to to moderate our
panel Corey is the editor-in-chief of
Discover Magazine who many of you know
is the nation's leading general interest
Science and Technology magazine during
his 11 year tenure at discover Corey has
moved through the ranks of web director
news editor features editor an executive
editor to the top of the pecking order
as editor-in-chief we will forgive him
for wasting those four years in
Cambridge his areas of expertise include
astronomy space exploration alternative
energy emerging diseases and
environmental toxins climate change and
the topic of this evenings broadcast
evolution and creationism Corey welcome
to New Haven we're glad you saw the
light a person I want to I want to thank
you all for being here I want to I think
the Templeton Foundation for joining and
in this event and especially for the
three panelists I mean three marvelous
and really really free thinking people
here who I think are gonna kind of frame
this discussion in ways that I have were
a bit different than the way you've
heard of frames before yeah one of
things that that kind
treat me about this event is you know it
at discover we regularly get reader mail
from people who accused us of having a
you know an atheistic materialist agenda
that we we push evolution we push global
warming yeah we have yeah we're we're
part of some this this this cabal of you
know of hard materialist with this
secret hidden agenda and then we're you
know co-sponsoring this event with the
Templeton Foundation and I know from
Gary Rosen they hear all the time from
people who say you've got the secret you
know spiritual religious event you know
agenda you're trying to ear Trier trying
to you know kind of kind of push
religion into into all these debates you
know it and so you know it tickles means
in some sense and and but there's
actually I mean to serve a much more
serious agenda here which is that you
know I think people tend to think of
these questions and very impala terms
and simplistic terms there are actually
some interesting evolutionary reasons of
why people might do that what I'm hoping
to do here is is really you know address
this big question you know does this
this evolution explain human nature it's
a you know talk about a big question I
mean that's that's something that's it's
way more than we can possibly chew off
in the course of a you know 'litham of
an hour-long panel but you know I think
we have there are three perspectives
here that I think will help make sense
of this question so let me start by
actually just kind of framing the
question in slightly more concrete terms
because I think you know human human
nature is such a such a big idea it's
such a bit such a big term I think you
know most of us it is sort of a
common-sense level you know identified
there's certain things of human nature
that we think of as being the most human
you know consciousness freewill and
morality and I think you know the
conversation we're talking about here is
kind of get a frame human nature in
those terms not entirely defined in
those terms but but you know that's sort
of the focal point in the conversation
guys each of you to kind of introduce
yourself quickly you know you're you
know give your you know your affiliation
describe your work and just give me
quickly kind of your perspective on this
question of you know does evolution
explain human nature you know I'm not
probably not expecting a yes or no but
although I'd welcome yes or no but but
you know sort of what what your what
research is and so what perspective it
gives you on that question so let me let
me start with with Ken Miller my name is
Ken Miller I'm a cell biologist
I work on biological membrane structure
and function but I have broad interest
in biology as awful lot of people who
teach and write about biology do I'm the
co-author with a terrific guy named Joel
Levine of a whole series of high school
and college general biology textbooks
that are used all over the country the
these textbooks have drawn me into
public arguments about how the theory of
evolution is taught presented and
understood it gave me the honor although
I'm not sure that's the right word of
being the lead witness in the kicks
Miller versus Dover intelligent design
trial in federal court in Pennsylvania
in 2005 and I've also written on the
interface between science and religion
I've written a book called finding
Darwin's God a scientist search for
common ground between God and evolution
arguing that in fact there are ways that
religious people can understand the
evolutionary process so I'm broadly
interested in evolution and very much
interested in communicating science to
the public and promoting general public
understanding of science okay wonderful
our second panelist tonight is Laurie
Santos who has maybe a sort of a more
integrated view of biology you want to
talk about what you do yes so I'm Laurie
Santos I'm a professor of psychology
here at Yale University and I actually
try to study the evolutionary origins of
human nature so I'm really kind of
ingrained in this question as a work but
I try to look at it from a slightly
different perspective than you might
think I actually try to take a slightly
comparative look at human nature trying
to see what can we really understand
about human nature by studying our
closest evolutionary relatives so we're
trying to look at what aspects of human
nature do we actually share with
non-human primates and which aspects are
actually different so I really try to
take a more of an empirical approach to
trying to get at this question and and
that's kind of the perspective that I
come to it from Preserve thinking about
humans from the perspective of what are
we sharing and what are we not sure with
non-human primates okay and then I think
robbing the campus further we have a we
have David Sloan Wilson and I'm David
Stern Wilson I'm an evolutionist from
Binghamton University and I study
evolution
not only in the biological sciences but
with respect to all things human and I'm
quite passionate about the fact that
evolution is so very relevant and needs
to expand beyond the biological sciences
I do this in my own work in addition to
programmatically I've started a
campus-wide program on this on the
subject and two of the subjects that I
work on which I'm sure is going to come
up here is for in the first place
individuals versus groups altruism
versus selfishness which is so much
concerned with morality and in the
second place there being more devolution
than genetic evolution the culture and
also some psychological processes count
as evolutionary and therefore Annette
has a consequences for how we think
about human nature you actually let me
pick up quickly on something that you
just mentioned the morality and
specifically altruism you know the
things that we think of as you know
quintessentially human if not uniquely
human where where did the where did
altruism come from is altruism
you know I distinctly human trait and
this or is it is it an evolved trait
where do you where did it come from
and what is what is the utility of it if
it's if it's something if it's something
that's not it's not you know sort of
imposed from top down where could
altruism have come from I can I think I
can give a one minute history because I
but basically the reason that altruism
is so puzzling to the evolutionary
imagination is that it is just a
contagious it is locally disadvantageous
if you put an altruist in a selfish
individual next to each other the
selfish individual wins
we hope altruism evolves but if it's
locally disadvantageous how can it
evolve in the total population and the
answer is is that it's advantageous at a
larger scale it groups about true as
some solid citizens of all sorts can
survive and reproduce better than groups
of individuals that are not so
altruistic and this very simple formula
applies throughout nature so the first
answer to your question is by no means
as altruism defined in that way confined
to humans and in the second place humans
practice altruism in addition to
selfishness with a vengeance and
among non relatives perhaps more than
perhaps more than other species so our
altruism is distinct but what's so very
interesting about altruism is that it's
such a fundamental issue for all social
behaviors all creatures all social
behaviors and so there's a big stage in
which we can examine the large but still
smaller subject of altruism in humans so
that naturally leads me to back to back
to Larry Sanchez who actually is looking
at nonhumans what do you see do you I
mean do you see altruistic behavior and
what does it tell you about but the
difference between human altruism and
altruism in other species well I mean
it's a puzzle right because on the one
hand other primates are pretty much just
as social as humans right they have all
the same sort of evolutionary puzzles
that being a social organism poses for
you but you don't see the kind of non
kin altruism that you see and the human
species like so robustly your humans are
just nice to non-kin anonymously we're
willing to do all these wonderful things
you know we donate blood we you know go
into the military we give our lives do
all these things you just don't actually
see primates doing that and so the
empirical question that primate
researchers starting to face is well why
is that you know we just not seeing the
right kinds of things or can we actually
see some sort of altruistic behavior
actually playing out and the empirical
answer right now seems to be that it's a
complicated and difficult to to get at
kind of problem some primate species
seem to show behaviors that are very
altruistic so they're really willing to
take a cost to themselves to actually do
things that are fair to others to do
things that help others but it's not
true of other primate species so some
species do some peach tree some species
don't it seems like it's an
unfortunately complicated problem right
now that we don't have a great grasp of
but David really nicely stated the
problem which is that all social species
actually faced this issue of they would
do better if everyone was kind of nice
but it seems like humans perhaps
uniquely have some approximate
mechanisms to actually do this nice
behavior so it's it's a bit of a puzzle
both kind of theoretically and
empirically right now well let me
actually follow up with with that
because you're doing specific studies I
mean what do you say when you when you
actually you know kind of boil this down
to a specific experiment I mean how do
you study ultras
how do you actually how do you actually
look at the primates and what what kinds
of behaviors do you seem how what what's
uniquely human and what is it what what
seems to be more generous oh so I'll
give you the actual practical kind of
data that we see in the lab that we're
trying to make sense of right now so my
student Chrissy Lyme Gruber has actually
done this wonderful study in
collaboration with France well where she
said you know had no cost of themselves
will a capuchin monkey who's a new world
monkey you know kind of relative of
humans 35 million years ago will they do
something nice for someone else so if I
was a Capuchin my dad had the
opportunity to actually give food to Ken
I could choose to give foo tip or not
give food to him I know console myself
so what do I do and it turns out that
capuchins are nice if they have the
opportunity to be nice so if you're
looking at me and I see you I'll
actually give you the food but as soon
as I no longer see you and importantly
as soon as Ken no longer sees me then
rather than just kind of not being nice
anymore I get very spiteful so rather
than do something that is nice to you
actually do something that's actively
mean to you and so here are the kind of
findings that were coming out in the
primate literature but it seems like on
the one hand you know I care about being
nice to can I care about what Ken thinks
of me but then on the other hand it's
slightly more complicated than then it
seems like under some situations
primates are actually nice but under
some situations they're actually kind of
mean so it it gets very complicated in
terms of empirical answer to some of
these kinds of questions
so can I mean that that that sort of
naturally that you've been deprived of
food or something something well or give
me some food at dinner tonight right so
that takes some of the sting out of it
no I'm actually I'm actually curious I
mean I mean you were you were in sort of
ground zero of a lot of these debates
you mentioned the being at the Dover
trial the you know the serve I mean the
I mean the proximate issue at hand and
the Dover trial was intelligent design
but I feel like I mean the the deeper
the deeper issue in a lot of these you
know debates between science and
creations or science and intelligent
design I think really is this issue of
morality the other guy's right yeah the
idea that science is sort of
materialistic and amoral
religion is you know is spiritual and
moral and that that the you know I think
there's this with this very you know
kind of schematic argument then develops
that you have to choose between those
two but that's not exactly the argument
and that's not the perspective that you
were presenting at Dover can you sort of
talk a little bit about sort of happy
with the perspective that you brought to
that trial and sort of how it kind of
relates to what we're talking well that
well the Dover trial had a lot of very
specific issues that are really outside
of the purview of what we're talking
about tonight and in particular what had
happened was a school board in
Pennsylvania had decided to require its
teachers to prepare a curriculum on
intelligent design teachers refused to
do that school board believer not wrote
their own intelligent design lesson had
it read to the students that's the sort
of thing that the eleven parents in the
district objected to they filed a
lawsuit so when the trial opened my job
in a sense and I first spent the first
two days of the trial on the stand was
to explain what the basis of
evolutionary theory was what the
evidence was for evolution I also knew
that expert witnesses for intelligent
design we're going to follow me and
therefore I had to explain to the judge
what they would say what their reasoning
would be and then why it was wrong in
advance of them coming up because trials
are not debates you have to present your
case first and I knew I wouldn't get to
follow them and obviously I and the
other witnesses on our side did a good
job of explaining to the judge what you
would hear from the other side and why
it was wrong and he certainly remember
that those lessons and wrote an
absolutely extraordinary decision an
intelligent design wasn't science that
it was primarily a religious religiously
motivated doctrine and it could not
disentangle itself his words from its
creationist roots but to me one of the
things that I'm always amazed at perhaps
I shouldn't be is the intensity with
which many people will resist any
mention of evolution and it's because
just as you mentioned to them it robs
their lives of meaning and purpose and
value and it disqualifies any notion of
morality as if when you take when you
say that we are creatures of matter
which we surely are that we were shaped
by evolution which we surely were that
evolution produced our bodies it
produced our brains and I think in many
respects evolution produced our minds
therefore you say there's no such thing
as morality is no such thing as right
and wrong well I don't think that
follows at all and I think it fought I
think it doesn't follow for a lot of
reasons in a way what the evolutionary
process does
is to explore solutions to the world
around us one solution is to be small
metabolize quickly and broke wickley
that's what a bacterium does another
solution is to be big and sexy and
photosynthetic that's what an oak tree
does so you can think of an oak tree
it's very sexy and another solution is
to have a large highly developed highly
adaptable and programmable nervous
system and in a sense that is our
solution as well and I'm perfectly at
home with the idea and I think most
biologists who work in the evolution of
human behavior at home with the idea
that the evolutionary process has shaped
our moral sense that the process of kin
selection which is one of the one of the
ways in which altruistic behavior is
generally assumed to have evolved that
this process has given us a sense of
what's right and what's wrong that helps
to shape our behavior now you haven't
asked any of us directly to into that
question which is this evolution
explained human nature no we're able to
get there and and my quick answer and
I'll leave it open for the other
panelists would be the evolution yes
explains human nature but it doesn't
explain all of it and I think that's a
good point for me to stop talking okay
well yeah actually
let me follow that that line through and
then I have I want to follow up on a
couple things you said does evolution
explain human nature yes in the up or
down and possibly all of it but not yet
David does evolution explain human
nature only when you appreciate that
there's more evolution than genetic
evolution and when you do and when you
appreciate that individuals are
evolutionary outcomes and that cultures
are evolutionary outcomes then it's also
the case that is unique products of
evolution individuals have natures and
cultures have natures that are different
from each other and so the idea of a
universal human nature is only true for
a subset of traits those traits that are
really part of our innate genetic
repertoire so what's so interesting
about thinking of other evolutionary
processes is that it enables us to say
that as an entire species we do not have
a single human nature for the very
reason that cultures and individuals are
outcomes of their own evolutionary
processes
that's a great thing to follow up on
because I again I think you know the the
idea of you serve you know nature red in
tooth and claw you know the kind like
that this or like the classic
competitive view of evolution is still a
very prevalent way of how I think you
know lay people even a lot of scientists
think about it evolution as you know as
a one-on-one competition or maybe or
maybe like I've liked them you know it
was a small group versus small group
competition but what you're talking
about is you know a kind of
multi-layered view of evolution can you
talk a little bit more about like how
does that actually play out one of the
points I want to make is that one of the
most important developments in
evolutionary theory is called major
transitions and what major transitions
tells us is that as amazing as it might
seem with the individuals of today are
the social groups of past ages and the
first person to develop this theory was
lynn margulis and you might very well
know that theory of the symbiotic cell
that the nucleated cell did not evolve
by small you mutational steps from
bacterial cells but as groups
communities of bacteria are becoming so
integrated that they become an organism
in their own right and much more
recently
I think what's emerging which solves a
lot of problems about our human
uniqueness is that human evolution
represents a major transition and that's
why we're so much more cooperative
basically then although cooperation
certainly exists in other primate
species the reason we're so much more
cooperative is because this transition
happens and what a transition is is a
shift and the balance between levels of
selection so that whereas before there's
like plan a and plan B for how to
succeed plan a is succeeding at the
expense of your neighbor
Plan B is succeeding collectively as a
group compared to other groups and a
major transition is is basically a
suppression of plan a so that Plan B
becomes the the main force in evolution
now let me just make one slight more
point because the idea of morality from
an evolutionary perspective is not just
being considered by us evolutionist but
it's also being considered by the best
moral philosophers of our time
and one book is called the evolution of
morality by Richard Joyce who says this
if altruism was purely instinctive yeah
we wouldn't even count as moral we would
not recognize as its moral what's so
distinct about morality human morality
is a sense of obligation that we might
not be moral but we're obligated to be
moral and so that sense of human
obligation of kind of being locked into
a system in which in which are held
accountable and other individuals make
sure that you're accountable that goes
beyond instinctive altruism and that
kind of locked in the system when you
study it is astonishingly similar to the
kind of locked in system that causes
genes for example to obey themselves in
individuals the rules of meiosis for
example which is the fair allocation of
genes into the next generation becomes
like a moral rule basically a rule of
fairness and so the isomorphism between
a human moral system and this more
sophisticated sense beyond instinct of
altruism and the kind of regulatory
systems which cause individuals to
function well precisely because
selection from within has been
foreclosed is astonishing and that's not
even a comparison between humans and
primates as fascinating as that might be
that's a comparison between humans as a
product of a major transition compared
to other major transitions way back in
the history of life the question of why
in primates you don't see a shift from
the kind of plan a reproductive success
to the plan B reproductive success I
mean in practice they have all of the
features that you should have for humans
right they have extremely strong group
affiliation where their bond with their
group which ways they stay with for long
periods of time actually affects their
success so groups can out-compete other
groups for other for food sources they
can out-compete other groups for access
to water and so on it's just unclear why
the primates don't then have the shift
so the real question I think winds up
being at the proximate level is here
what are the kinds of mechanisms that
allow for human altruism to develop and
why don't you see those kinds of
proximate mechanisms play
in the in the primates yeah and I think
I think one of the things that just
speaking from the biological point of
view that melds into this is if you read
the Origin of Species by Charles Darwin
you can be struck by the fact that he
confesses in three places that he just
cannot explain altruistic behavior in
animals he talks about the social
insects he talks about cooperation
between animals and he flatly says I
really can't make any sense of this
because if behavior is inherited and
subject to natural selection that
behavior should favor the individual and
should not favor someone else so Darwin
says as he did famously because he was
very honest about what he didn't
understand don't get it well what
happens of course in the the middle of
the 20th century is Rd Hamilton Robert
rivers and others come along with a
theory called kin selection and that kin
selection says that if you have an
instinctive motivation towards
altruistic behavior altruistic means I
help you at my own expense I have a
behavior that is a detriment to me but
helps you what they explained very
clearly is if there's an instinctive
motivation for such behavior a gene for
it to put it crudely that gene can
succeed even though it's to the
detriment of my survival if that
behavior is directed towards close
relatives towards offspring or kin
that's why it's called kin selection
because it helps - it tends to favor
individuals who might carry a copy of
the same gene and makes the group more
successful but the difficulty as was
brought up is that humans in particular
and many other primates display
altruistic behavior to a much larger
circle and this is what I meant when I
said I'm not sure that evolution
explains everything about human nature
because this cooperativity is really
there now david has brought up the idea
of evolution of social groups and
evolution of culture and there is no one
human nature because there are many
cultures on this planet I tend to use a
narrower definition of evolution as
evolution of the biological sense and to
me the notion of cultural evolution or
the evolution of music or the evolution
of political systems is more of a
metaphor that uses the word evolution as
opposed to evolution in the biological
sense so I think biological evolution
gives us the tool produces the brain
produces the instinctive behaviour but
we go further than that we invent
mathematics we compose music we write
poetry all of these things happen on the
basis of the
of the toolkit that evolution gave us
but I think they transcend the
evolutionary the purely evolutionary
explanation of human nature okay I have
to let you here this is science right
scientists disagree right that's very
good that and I would beg to differ with
you with respect to just the history and
I think that Darwin actually perceived
very clearly how altruism evolves on the
strength of groups of Alturas doing
better than groups have done now trust
but I really at this point want a segue
to culture and focus not on Darwin but
on his forgotten figure among most
people and that is a Pierre TL de
chardin the French paleontologist who
was also a Catholic Jesuit priest and
who wrote the book phenomenon of man
which I'm sure you've read in addition
to other books and I had the opportunity
to read that book closely very recently
and was actually astonished at how
current it is because it's not read by
my colleagues at all it's grad mostly
for its spiritual value or anyone who
reads it now reads it primarily for its
spiritual value but I was amazed at how
current was scientifically and what
shardene did I think was absolutely
extraordinary because that book and his
vision is 100% naturalistic he does not
invoke intervention anywhere not for the
original life now for the region of
humans not for anything and yet that
book is just penetrated with
spirituality and he's using the word
spirit and so all the time and do Ethan
that he can do that as he says that what
was what was amazing about human
evolution was that it was the birth of a
new evolutionary process and that for
him made human origins as significant as
the original life because the last time
an evolutionary process had been created
it was the original life now we have
some new process that had taken place
some variation in selection process what
is evolution but variation and selection
and so this was now a variation of
selection of ideas or reflection as he
put it but which is different in some
respects but in every other respect
obeys the rules of evolution and so
chardon and i think this is really the
way to go so this is
a great debate we could have here and we
can continue is that cultural evolution
is fundamentally like biological
evolution and we can get so much mileage
out of that the other than thinking of
it as merely a metaphor and so I think
that what we've identified here is a
real debate point amongst the experts
right so this is it folks
state-of-the-art science taking place
right in front of you no argument the
cultural evolution is real but my
argument is is that human nature is
fundamentally biological and affected by
the cultures in which we grow up and for
me then the notion of evolution
explaining human nature is in fact that
biological evolution culture culture is
transient you can adopt a child from one
culture raised him in another he's in
that other culture and I think for me as
a biologist the interesting question is
how much of our biology explains that
human nature the influencer is a great
deal but not a hundred percent well
we're just jumping it with an empiricist
right here in the middle is jumping it
as a psychologist there's actually some
common ground here which is the question
of well if culture evolution is so
powerful in a shapes human nature so
much why don't we see cultural evolution
and other species and it turns out that
again the might the answer might
actually be in the psychology turns out
that it seems like some of the proximate
mechanisms so you might need for culture
things like imitating you know so I see
you using your fork some later I see
David using chopsticks some way and I
imitate that and then take that to the
next level and give it meaning and so on
those types of very simple mechanisms
don't seem to be the kind of thing that
other primates can do very well seems
like even though the old adage is that
kind of monkey-see monkey-do
in fact monkeys don't see and do they
they just don't seem to have a the
wherewithal the kind of copy others
whereas humans do this to a fault and in
fact there's some lovely developmental
research showing that if a human child
sees a human adult doing a behavior
that's actually just wrong it's actually
just not a good way to do things they'll
actually copy it even though they're
they're kind of getting the wrong result
and what it seems like is that this kind
of behavior of copying some of these
mechanisms that might drive culture like
imitation and so on are so powerful that
they might bring human children to the
opposite result the cool thing is that
primates actually don't show this but
that might actually explain why you see
cultural mechanisms driving human
evolution and the changes in human
nature that you don't see now this is
completely these proximities are
completely agnostic as to the way these
things play out once you have proximate
mechanisms before it leaves that point
actually I do want to follow up because
I mean there have been reports certainly
in the way that the way of the report in
the in the in the popular media you know
of you know chimpanzee populations that
differ from other chimpanzee populations
and they're in there in you know in tool
use things that are popular presented as
evidence that that actually certain
chimpanzee cultures certain certain
shippin see populations as you do have
culture they do have transmitted
cultures or I mean in in dolphins also I
mean but you're saying that those things
are are limited or fundamentally
different from what you see in humans
the claim is that the mechanism in
humans is just far more slavish that the
act of seeing human behave in a way
serve drives another you've been to
behave in that way it actually changes
their cognition at the problem so is
this lovely study with chimpanzees done
by Andy white and its colleagues where
they set up this little puzzle box for
chimpanzees and chimpanzees see this
puzzle box they don't actually know how
to operate it but if they were to see
another human operate it they could
figure it out they can say oh the human
did this behavior in this behavior I'm
going to copy that exactly human
children do the same thing now you just
change the situation so the puzzle box
is sort of obvious it's clear and it's
very clear to the chimpanzee and anyone
who looks at how the puzzle box works
and now I see you as a human do some
kind of crazy thing on the puzzle box as
a chimpanzee say I'm a very smart German
see I'm just gonna do what I'm supposed
to do but you give the same problem to a
human child a three-year-old and they'll
watch what you do and do it exactly the
incorrect way that you did it so it's
kind of this cultural mechanism for
driving the kinds of behaviors that are
seen rather than the ones that you can
kind of figure out on your own so in
terms of thinking of the balance of
these kind of mechanisms you might have
mechanisms to say well I understand how
physics works I'm just going to sort it
out versus I have mechanisms that say a
good thing to do is to copy what I see
others do it seems like humans err on
that side but but the power of that sort
of mechanism actually allows for this
kind of cultural learning that we see
robustly because there are other animals
there are other animals that do what you
sort of but don't buy on expert I yeah
what you said humans do and the classic
example I can think of is the song
sparrow
and when a baby sparrows raised in
isolation it has this little primitive
song in order to learn the full song of
the adult it has to be exposed to other
adults singing the right song and if
it's only exposed to the songs of adults
of another species it will develop a
defective song so in that sense it's
sort of pre-programmed to acquire a
particular song and there's some very
clever experiments in which baby song
sparrows reared in isolation are
presented with four songs from different
species and they have the capability to
hear their species song imitate it and
learn a full song properly No doesn't
that fall into the kind of imitation
that you're talking about respecting it
the idea is that if you had a kind of
little sort of toggle switch on how much
imitation you would do that the human
toggle switch you know falls at 11 as it
were we're just so influenced by the
kinds of behaviors that we see in others
that were really robustly able to
imitate them I really have derived in
Matt Damon in a way that maybe other
animals down perhaps save songbirds but
at least across primates you just don't
see the kind of invitation that you see
in humans so you might get some sort of
cultural traits that you see some kind
of ratcheting but not nearly the kind of
ratchet you see sort of a question of
creativity and freewill and how much of
that is you know is uniquely ours as
opposed to something that's sort of
that's shared species quick points first
of all evolution makes use of anything
that is reliable in the environment and
so if birdsong adult birdsong is
reliable in the environment then baby
birds will make use of that because it
is so reliable that's point one point
and that will be a form of culture point
two we are living in the Golden Age of
cultural evolution and studied a
nonhuman species so culture is more
important and more non-human species
including creatures like Guppies that
you wouldn't think you know not higher
animals but then we ever knew okay about
0.3 that's still a far shot from our
kind of culture now the three aspects of
human uniqueness or specialness that
we've been talking about I call them the
3 C's culture cognition and cooperation
there is a real tendency this was also
true tl hard as a historical note to
focus on our reasoning ability our
no mental abilities is like the
signature thing that has to be explained
first okay and what's emerging I think
and I think it's a rapidly emerging
consensus is that of the three C's
cooperation came first and KY the
special aspects of cognition and culture
that we associated with humans our forms
of cooperation and just think of it you
know the human infant that I see and
that I'll do something that makes no
sense but I copy it there has to be a
degree of trust in their society so
that's a sensible thing to do without
any other information and even though
primate troops are trusting to a degree
memories of a group are still their
primary rivals I mean the males are
still obsessed with being the alpha
males and the females are still being
obsessed with being the the top lineage
and matriarchy and the competition among
members of a group is sufficiently great
so that you're not well advised just to
do something that somebody else does
because there's not that degree of trust
and so the concept of cooperation is the
first thing and that everything else
that's special about our species is a
variety of cooperation think about
language symbolic thought beliefs
none of these are private or individuals
all of these are traded so I think that
is simple to understand
but in revolutionary that that we can
save these tweets three C's one of them
came first and the rest of them could be
understood in terms of that first thing
okay you you you yeah you touched on
there toward the end too obviously one
of the one of the big issues or ideas
hanging over this question which is you
know we people talk about you know
evolution versus human nature I religion
or belief I mean that's that's a you
know that that's sort of a that's kind
of a elephant the room that's you know
that's what drives a lot of the debate
that's what a lot of people the way a
lot of people frame this how does how
does how does religion I'm going to just
believe you know how does that play out
in the kind of the interpretation that
you're describing here it is you can
religious belief then be described in
terms of evolution may I go first yes
let me let me start out
I want to go first in part because I'm
so deeply involved in this subject and I
can also plug not plug but thank the
Templeton Foundation for investing in
this for as long as they have in a way
that no other funding agency there's no
way that the National Science Foundation
of the National Institute of Health is
going to fund this kind of research we
hope that they do in the future but over
the last ten years or so the field of
studying religion from an evolutionary
perspective has grown into a respected
and sophisticated scientific discipline
that I'm very much involved in and
what's so exciting about it is that you
can take the toolkit that evolution is
used to study genetic evolution and it's
extraordinarily how you can move it over
just out of your cultural phenomenon
such as religion so and once again
returning to our point as to whether we
can think of cultural evolution in this
case religion as one aspect of cultural
evolution using the same tool kit that
evolutionists use to study genetic
evolution and our time here is brief but
I look forward to continuing the
conversation I want to say not only yes
but demonstrably so in the case of the
study of religion well so it kind of I
want to let you respond in part in part
because I mean you've you've written
about this and talked a fair bit about
basically you know having your you know
having your feet in two camps of having
you know having religious faith and and
you know I'm very you know a clear-eyed
view of what of what science can do you
know at the same time does that that
means that does that split you in half
does that make your answer sort of yes
and no itself no absolutely not and and
I think that you know I mean it's worth
noting that 40% of the members of triple
ask the American Association of the
Advancement of science the largest
scientific organization in the world
professor religious belief of some sort
so it's not at all uncommon for
scientists to be religious it's worth
noting the darwin's first great
proponent in north america was the was
the Harvard botanist ASA Gray who was
himself a very devout presbyterian
Toshio dobzhansky probably the greatest
popular evolutionary population
geneticist of the 20th century was also
a Christian so there this is not at all
uncommon but the the notion and I think
this is this is a bit what David was
getting at that the religious impulse
the the impulse to try to come to grips
with everything you see about you with
with the universe himself with human
existence with the sense of morality in
religious terms
it is hardwired into us it's built into
us and it gives us something that my
friend Steven Pinker at Harvard has
called a god module within the brain in
the sense that we tend to try to
construct religious explanations for
things do I find that reasonable and
plausible and biological evolutionary
terms
sure I do absolutely do I find that that
disqualifies religion therefore as a
serious explanation for these big
questions the answer that is no and the
reason I would put it that way is if the
very same process of evolution that gave
us the God module that that gave us the
tendency to look for these overarching
and perhaps spiritual otherworldly
explanations for things that
evolutionary process also gave us a
tendency to look for empirical and
logical explanations and to like those
we call that science it gave us an
aesthetic sense we call those those
aesthetic sense we reflect them in art
and music so I think ultimately one
cannot disqualify with the notion of
faith itself by saying that the
religious impulse is produced by
evolution anymore than you can
disqualify the scientific impulse by
saying that it was produced by evolution
as well so I think ultimately we have to
use those big brains that evolution gave
us in a way that tries to make sense of
nature and we have to do it in a way
that we think is sensible and logical
and reasonable and I think for many
people myself included religious faith
is part of that explanation that sits
right alongside science and in many ways
complements it so I mean there's an
interesting dichotomy they've described
there on the one hand being able to
think of even even even your your your
own attraction to to religion as
something that's produced you know in a
basically a materialistic way through
evolution and at the same time that the
attractions of that explanation does not
des legitimize that that's right I mean
I mean CS Lewis once wrote God likes
matter he invented it and I think that I
think that's a very good way to explain
why much of human nature it has in fact
materialist explanations to it and
ultimately I think to be a scientist is
to subscribe to a materialist paradigm
meaning the world of matter and energy
the laws of physics in chemistry or how
we explain ourselves in our own
existence
but that's that's sufficient in a
scientific explanation but not but not
sufficient to you in a personal sense
well it's it's not sufficient in the
sense you have to ask yourself why does
this world of matter and energy exist
why is there something rather than
nothing why is it that science works so
well well what is there about the
logical order of this universe that
enables us to make sense of it and you
can simply say well it's just the way it
is not not worth asking further or you
can say that there's a greater
explanation that encloses all of this
and I think ultimately whether a person
is a theist or not you still have that
question out there which is evolution
gave us these big brains evolution gave
us the consciousness we have evolution
gave us the ability to develop a sort of
cultural that whose evolution david has
talked about what does that mean in
terms of the validity of these impulses
is there such a thing as truth is there
the good life as the Greek philosophers
used to ask and I think ultimately I
think there are real questions to this I
think there there are real answers to
the questions of what is right what is
wrong is or is there such a thing in
reality as good and evil or are these
two things actually just social
constructions I think those are real
values well Laurie I mean you give an
opportunity to actually think about this
day to day you know you're sitting on
one side of the cage the your your yeah
your your subjects they're sitting on
the other side obviously you you think
that there's some moral difference
between the two of you have a lot of
time to think about this way I mean well
it's it's very hard for us to ask about
the validity of the impulses but we can
definitely ask about the history of the
impulses and and the funny thing about
primates is that you know obviously
primates are not very religious we don't
see them praying out in the wild when we
go study them and so on
but beyond that they they're just not
very explanatory
like so the very simple explanatory
drive that you see in any three-year-old
that's bugging you about why this why
that we just don't seem to see that kind
of drive in primates they sort of take
the world as it is and they don't kind
of go deeper to kind of find those
explanations so it seems like the
explanatory drive just seems to be
absent from them which which might be a
reason why you don't see them thinking
about the bigger kinds of validity
questions of what these sort of impulses
like the kind of things that humans do
all the time of why are we here and so
on not the kind of why questions they
ask so I think this question of where
did this impulse come from even in a
very broader sense of just explaining
anything kind of scientific explanations
as opposed to a religious explanation
it's kind of why humans do that is a big
question and it's unfortunately one that
the comparative researchers don't don't
have a good grasp on it seems like other
species out there don't do that we do
why we do is kind of a big open question
well I mean David natural segue to your
work by David why I mean the I mean the
why questions which are you know which
start as the you know concern is very
personal individualistic question I mean
the way it usually comes out is it turns
into a belief system it turns into a
sort of a group a group behavior rather
than an individual behavior well when
you take culture and cultural evolutions
sufficiently seriously you become a new
kind of social constructivist the old
kind of social constructivist tends to
be anti evolution basically saying
hardly anything comes from our genes
everything comes from our culture so on
and so forth I want to say you're right
but you need to be a sophisticated
evolutionist in order to really
understand the implications of that so
what does it mean that our culture's are
so important that they really do dictate
our behavior is in the approximate sense
distally of course the genes are evolved
the genes genetic evolution is required
to explain the whole architecture that
gives us the capacity to do that but
once evolved there is so much that human
has to learn that's why we have a
stretched-out life cycle right that's
why we're not sexually mature until 16
or 18 whatever we have so much so very
much to learn and and and that whole
system has to be so complicated that
it's like the system of genetic
replication and
expression so at this point now we're
talking about cultures as meaning
systems and a very durkheimian sense
that's another person that needs to be
revised basically we're talking about
cultures groups not individuals and
we're talking about very complicated
meaning systems that coordinate our
behaviors and and and so on and so forth
I think that thinking of meaning systems
rather than a religion per se I think
religion is a variety of meaning of a
meaning system and when you look at the
importance of factual knowledge I think
the actual knowledge sometimes
contributes to a meaning system and in
that case we believe those facts and
when it doesn't then we abandon those
facts no matter what they're evidential
content so thinking of meaning systems
not religion and the trade-off between
factual knowledge and survival value for
meaning systems I think this is setting
the stage appropriately generally so
that we can now study religion as large
a topic as that is as something smaller
within that larger story of cultural
evolution and meaning systems and even
though there's a tremendous variety of
meaning systems possible in fact we
could even say anything those any we
could imagine any meaning system might
be produced which was what a social
constructivist might say that's not true
on the winnowing end as far as what
survives the winnowing process for
cultural systems is as strong and
ruthless in a sense and as for a
biological system and so the only
meaning systems we have left to look at
are ones that have survived a winnowing
process and are therefore adapted to
their environments in the same way as a
biological species let me ask you a
question and jumping from that if we
come back this question sort of like
frame human nature into these these two
sides the the you know that I mean the
scientific worldview and then and the
you know the the non set and the non
side of a belief world vo tried to turn
out to college just the specific route
your village in particular it's it's
actually easy for me to see how how a
belief system that really you know that
emits a group together that provides a
shared identity I can see the
evolutionary benefit of that I mean look
viewed that way it seems to me that you
know that
devoting your life to you know studying
particle physics is kind of maladaptive
like you're not you're not going to have
a lot of friends you're not yet you're
not part of a very large community I
think maybe the question is why does
human nature include those kinds of
scientific belief systems if they're if
they're not really helping you in that
and they in that group sense well I
would I would argue very strongly that
scientific belief systems are not
maladaptive in fact if you read just got
at least a few a few pieces are on Blair
if you read if you read it's use a
trivial example one of James Watson's
co-discoverer the double helix structure
one of James Watson's recent books and I
think the name of the book is genes
girls and gamal Watson sort of makes the
argument that being a science nerd is a
good way to meet chicks and the the
argument the argument here I think think
essentially is that people in science
whether they're the sort of
astrophysicist nerd that you described
or something like that the people in
science have a deep intellectual
curiosity and it's very hard for me to
believe that there's anything about
having an inquisitive mind and a deep
intellectual curiosity that it's really
now adaptive in any sense whatsoever I
think in many respects that's the
determining character of the human
species and it's one of the things that
has enabled us in biological terms to
really come to dominate this planet
which we surely do as a species we've
come to a great pause point in the in
the discussion that said this and I saw
medically sealed discussion up here on
the podium the point where we can open
it up to some I hope relatively well
adapted people out here in the audience
who can who could respond and challenge
maybe open up the conversation beyond
what we've done so far
I just wanted first of all I really want
to encourage people to ask questions but
I think this is a really this is a it's
a it's a great wide-ranging group of
people here in a very nice opportunity
to sound out things that we don't really
get that many opportunities to talk
about this way
there's one microphone over here so I
encourage people to come up ask
questions and just one
but the one caveat that that we have
cameras here you will appear on camera
you may appear on the web increases
reproductive success yeah yeah in the in
the broad sense yeah you you as a
professor at a humble State University I
am prepared to be dazzled by the
students Ivy League great Yale
University that we heard about in the
introduction and as a product of the the
institution of Cambridge Massachusetts I
reserve judgment
well hello I'm Richard Prum and I have
my degree from Harvard and my paycheck
comes from Yale so divided loyalties I'm
interested in exploring another aspect
of evolution and that is the something
hasn't been touched on which is that we
focused both at genetic levels and
cultural levels on the force of or the
role of adaptation in evolution but we
haven't even recognized at all that
there are evolutionary events that are
coincident or contingent or accidental
you know one of the one of the one of
the great concepts in this area is the
idea of a spandrel a structural feature
that occurs because of architecture
which suddenly because there gets a use
and as luetin and Ghul pointed out you
know the spandrels in San Marcos have
these beautiful carvings on them they
weren't invented or necessary for the
carvings once they were there I'd like
to hear the panelists discuss what
aspects of human nature might be
spandrels and is there a role what is
the role for contingent and other
incident levels perhaps in explaining
human nature or why some of us might do
particle physics and I can give a very
quick answer to a contingent aspect of
human nature and that is the need to
have vitamin C drink orange juice you
might know that you don't have to force
orange juice down the throats of your
cats or dogs they don't need it and the
reason for that is they are actually
able to synthesize ascorbate from
scratch we on the other hand are genetic
defectives we have a bro
and gene for the synthesis of ascorbate
and that's a contingent event and we
share that not with all primates but
with some so it's something that
happened at our evolutionary history is
good for the Minute Maid company and for
the makers of makers that's the example
of a contingent or chance of that in
terms of spandrels I will actually pick
a spandrel that I think is element of
human nature that is absolutely
essential to who we are that was flagged
as spandrel by golden luetin and that is
language and that is one of their
arguments is that the gray the brain
became very big and with a convoluted
cortex for some other selective purpose
and the consequence of that hyper
development of the nervous system of our
brain was in fact the ability to
manipulate symbols make sounds use those
as symbolic meetings and and therefore
develop language so I would argue that I
think the acquisition of language is
itself a spandrel agreement from the
panel question and just to fire off a
few quick answers I mean Gould was
preferring to service Lou Anton and
Google perform a service when they
emphasize that there's more evolution
than adaptation okay I think that if we
want to say that what's most special
about our species as a spandrel lots of
people do I mean that's a respectable
position I think it's actually a very
tenuous one because a spandrel unless it
gets worked upon and becomes an
adaptation in the case of language
almost by definition is not adaptive
except by some happy circumstance and so
if you pin your hopes on on what's most
special about humans not being adaptive
well good luck but I think actually
what's most special about humans is
sufficiently valuable that that it that
it is adaptive and then another point to
make I think is that the concept of
which you you touched upon of
adaptations traits they were adaptive in
the past but not the present mismatch
theory vitamin C is one but there is so
much else and there's really a sense in
which you know one of the first things
you need to know about evolution is that
only adapts you to your past environment
the environment of evolutionary
adaptiveness you change the outer
environment even a little bit a teensy
bit all deaths are off and what
previously was a
erricka love something working for you
becomes a nightmare something's that's
working against you an immune system
dysfunction there's no end of examples
of this and I think there's cultural
example so I think when we look at some
of the craziest things that are
happening in modern life
it's our cultural system which works
well in a small group context just doing
wacko things comparable to the immune
system dysfunction in modern life so
there's another example of the
importance of non adaptation basically
for for human affairs I mean obviously
and people have talked about belief in
God as a spandrel I mean is that I mean
I can fit in in terms of belief systems
of you know something that turns out to
to be evolutionarily adaptive even even
even if it comes out of a certain an
accident would you view it that way it's
an empirical question when I said that
the toolkit moves over what I meant to
say is is that there's not one
evolutionary theory of religion there's
six because there's six evolutionary
theories for everything or not if it's
adaptive as an adaptive at the group
individual level is it a cultural
parasite if it's non adaptive as a drift
is it a byproduct and so on and so forth
so it's an empirical question whether
God concept is adaptive or not and
science goes to work when it answers
those questions but to give one piece of
that knowing that time is brief one of
the things that I'm studying is
religious conceptions of the afterlife
and to focus on one that was should be
interest of is the concept of the
resurrection associated with early
Christianity I can report I think I can
I can think it can be established that
there's a cultural adaptation that arose
in a certain time in place for a
particular purpose so in that case and
in many other cases I think what the way
that the study of religion is going is
that although it could turn either way
the stuff could be a spand allure not we
are impressed by its adaptiveness
basically when we study them empirically
for long enough yeah there's obviously
easily another hour perhaps a year of
conversation that can follow here I want
to give other people a chance to ask
that some questions the question that
this whole debate is being spawned by is
does evolution explain human nature
which is a very strong claim
so somebody who wanted to argue against
us would just seem to find one
counterexample and say well here's a
component of human nature and it is not
or cannot be explained by the tools of
evolution so for any of you who think
that there might be some component of
human nature that cannot be explained by
evolution I'd just like to know what is
the counter example that comes to your
mind should we start with them actually
let me start with the primatologist here
I mean there's so many things that we do
that are indelible stands of human
nature that we probably don't have a
quick evolutionary explanation for this
all the kind of cultural stuff I mean I
think the the problem with this this
kind of strong claim and I think the
region that our moderator very kindly
dodged it is that there are different
ways that we could talk about really
explaining like do we really want a full
causal principle that explains although
very approximate facets of every aspect
of human nature I mean any of us that
we're making that strong claim would get
up here and look I think a little bit
crazy if we tried to like make those
strong claims right but the way I think
of the question of explaining is just
are we gonna actually constrain the
hypotheses that we have about some
particular aspect of human nature or
does evolution actually kind of provide
some insight that we wouldn't have
gotten from a non evolutionary way of
thinking about it
so that's my way of completely dodging
your hard question that I was hoping
that no one would ask up there but I
would dodge it but I'll answer it in a
different way okay and that is I think
what you're looking for is for someone
to say ah here's something that's in our
nature that was somehow put there by
some other force I can't identify
anything that to me looks like that but
here's the interesting thing a computer
operates according to Ohm's law does
Ohm's law therefore explained the world
of warcraft and I think the answer is no
because the the basic construction of
the electronics inside a computer is
what makes these higher level processes
possible so did evolution produce us our
nervous systems our brains in every
aspects of our bodies sure does that
mean it explains romani and geometry
does that mean that it explains higher
mathematics the answer is no I don't
think so evolution is the mechanism that
produced what we have but they're
elements of human nature that pertain
what we do with what we have that I
think ultimately are not really
explicable in terms of evolution not
because there's some sort of magical
mysticism that was tapped into our
bodies but because there are things that
we do that arise out of the evolutionary
toolkit but aren't directly explained by
evolution itself so I mean is that
evidence of the divine or is that just
evidence about the limitations what we
understand oh yeah oh just cuz someone's
a Christian doesn't mean always making
argues for the divine what without what
I'm saying exactly what up what I'm
really trying to defend in a sense is
the integrity of reason the integrity of
human thought which is to say that we
are not simply the slavish products of
evolution where there is an evolutionary
and adaptation 'el explanation for
everything we do and I think there are I
think you know I think reason is to be
respected I think mathematics is I
wouldn't say mathematics is pure but
mathematics is a very high level of
reasoning and I think it arises out of
our evolutionary toolkit but that
doesn't mean it's explained by it and
that's that's the way I answer the
question yeah thank you I'd like to
return them to the morality point really
quickly and you were discussing well
okay I'm a neuroscience student I
started studying neuroscience here on a
search sort of for objective morality
within the human mind right so I was
sort of convinced at the time that I
started studying this that we would be
able to find out somehow through science
like a means of objective truth so we
could say sort of you're human you have
these certain moral mechanisms within
you you're obligated because of that to
act in a certain way and in the past
year and a half or so that I've been
studying this and you know thinking
about it I've become less and less
convinced that science as a descriptive
entity can can really do that um and so
I was wondering if any of you are hold
the opposite view and I think maybe
Kenneth Miller you might do you think
that there are any any field or if it is
there any mechanism or way for
evolutionary biology or any field of
science to leave the descriptive domain
and enter into the prescriptive to
actually give people a sense of
obligation from scientific principles or
findings where in its some given such a
situation however small that they are
obligate attacked in this
okay I'll be glad to defer to my
colleagues to rephrase the question is
there a scientific morality sure sure
let me just a boil it down to the
question is there is there such a thing
as a scientific morality or is there a
moral code that's is derived well
through scientific inquiry I mean my
strong sense is that you can't get
normative claims from the kinds of
things that neuroscience can tell you
but well the naturalistic fallacy tells
us that values cannot be derived
entirely from facts okay on the other
hand values must consult facts in order
to come up with any prescription for how
to behave and so facts play an extremely
important role in a value system because
if a value system just by itself isn't
can't do anything without consulting the
facts of the world and so that makes
science by itself inadequate as a value
system but very important is a kind of a
consultant for a value system morality
it seems to me has an axiomatic
definition and when you read moral
philosophy I'm always a little bit
amused that this is like so axiomatic
that is hardly ever questioned morality
is fundamentally other and society
oriented it's just defined that way
evolution doesn't define it that way as
any moral philosophy we'll just take it
as a given it's like mathematics is that
is that something that's immoral is
something that's going to be is going to
contribute positively to others or to
society and there's some very
interesting exceptions to their rule so
I think that when you take the
everyone's definition of morality and
then you take the facts that science
gives us about the nature of our species
which can be everything from
neurobiological all the way up to and
many other levels you know function
proximate ultimate and so on and so
forth then we have new facts in fact
radically new facts in order to consult
with even a traditional value system and
I'll give the short answer which is I
think science can inform us in the
development of a moral sense but I don't
think science can determine morality
another question here
okay yeah and this this unfortunate
should be there the the last question of
the evening but fortunately the the this
the this conversation will will live on
online and and all three of these
presenters here have been very active in
engaging the in debates writing books
and publishing articles and in the this
is a this is a this is a debate and
discussion that will live on far beyond
this evening but living sure so there's
this concept of organic intellectual the
idea of questioning our assumptions as
scientists all the way down I mean I'm
wondering if there are any senses in
which possibly Western biases have
affected our thinking or even particular
findings about evolution and cultural
evolution and if evolution has been over
applied you don't want us to first go
ahead science is a human activity all
human activities are affected by the
cultures in which they take place and
since science as we understand it today
developed in Western Europe Transplant
of the United States and then later on
to eastern Asia it was affected by those
cultures so there's absolutely no
question about that
have certain ideas been over applied has
evolution been over applied all you have
to do is look at the eugenics movement
and immediately say yes that evolution
is often and over implied and over
interpreted so I think that's almost
it's almost a truism that the culture in
which science develops affects the way
in which that science is practice but I
think ultimately what gives me faith in
science is that science is a
self-correcting activity that there are
ways to correct these excesses you see
them in anthropology where the entire
field has spent a decade and a half of
recoiling
from the male perspective biases of the
practitioners of this particular field
and now we have a correction going on in
that in many other fields and I think as
science as a human activity spreads
throughout the world as the Eastern
cultures and others become more actively
involved in the scientific enterprise
they're going to provide whatever
correction is necessary to the Western
biases that are built into the science
that we do echo that completely I mean
you see the same kind
biases in the field of primate cognition
funny it's a gender bias as well
depending on the gender of the science
studying the primates but again you see
across time these sort of things
correcting themselves so unlike other
kinds of systems science actually have
this self correction mechanism in a way
that we hope will ultimately figure this
stuff out but yeah I think and I think
there is I mean falling from that
question there is a natural tendency
that you know you know when we talk
about human nature you know we think
about morality when we think about
morality we think about judeo-christian
morality which is what we're often you
know most of us in the room are dealing
with you know the you know the the
religion the religious battles with with
evolution are typically you framed in
terms of a very very Western type of
monotheism it's certainly it's sort of a
natural place to end this conversation
since you think in terms of you know you
were talking in terms of belief systems
you know defined in a way this much
broader than that then a few quick
points first of all everyone knows that
Bahrain and everyone else during that
time was influenced by the assumptions
of Victorian culture and that's studied
with a great deal of scholarly detail we
know in principle that the same thing
must be true now but it's very hard to
study and an ongoing way but there
should be is a self-conscious field of
science studies which takes place side
by side and examines those cultural
influences in a constructive way with
the actual scientific process okay and
that's something which hasn't taken
place because science studies people
actually a little bit hostile towards
science it turns out Enterprise has yet
to take place now it's not the case that
science is a self-correcting process
unless there's a diversity of use within
science if all the scientists in our
culture we have the same assumption then
there's nothing in science to be
self-correcting
and as a candidate cultural influence
for our time I would like to nominate
individualism the widespread assumption
that individuals are a privileged level
of the hutt of the hierarchy everything
can somehow be
playing as a form of self-interest I
think that what we need are serious
social historians to tell us why it is
that individualism became so prominent
not just in evolution but in everyday
culture in the social sciences at
roughly the same time in the middle of
the 20th century and how in many ways
the formal scientific theories such as
the theory of individual selection in
our field of evolutionary biology is a
tail being wagged by a larger cultural
dog and this is something which is only
now because in part because we're
suffering from the consequences of
individualism in our everyday lives and
societies now we're really beginning to
question as we need to you know what is
this axiomatic assumption of individual
self-interest
what is it done and how true is it it's
a wonderful place and and the
conversation where we where now that
we're done we not only don't know the
answer the question we don't even know
what human nature is that's we I mean
kidding aside I actually think that the
tearing down assumptions that you know
that you know the answer before you ask
the question is one of the most
important things that science can do and
that you know taking taking things you
know stripping them down like this and
trying to build up again is you know if
we're gonna arrive at a meaningful
answer and a meaningful sense of self
understanding that's that's how we're
going to do it so again I'd like to
extend a very very warm thanks to our
three speakers tonight who I think have
just been read a really tremendous level
of insight and sensitivity for the
question to the Templeton Foundation for
making as possible and to my my employer
for for for allowing me to do what I
love doing which is making it make a
science magazine where we can talk about
these things every month and thank you
all for being here